the thing is is that I make music to my  right music as well calvin harris and  john newman drop a new track just weeks  after calvin split from taylor swift but  is it about the bad blood singer men get  me in trouble John's new song is called  Olay Calvin wrote and produced it while  John provides the vocals on lyrics  including I ain't seen you Orban with  you for weeks but I see online that  you've begun to be a good girl and take  trips with your boyfriend and you've hid  in my name on your phone so you can call  me to tell me you've been going through  hell left him alone and you booked in a  hotel we're not gonna you know gossip  about each other yeah we probably  shouldn't be reading too much into those  words because the source tells ET the  song was written months ago while Taylor  was still with Calvin and is in no way  about the stars new romance with Tom  Hiddleston  you